KUNAL SONI: All right.
I'm back.
So so far, you've been hearing
a lot about cool product
initiatives,
features, tools, etc,
that can help you
improve the quality
of your mobile presence.
What we're going to do now
is something different.
We're going to talk to a
set of industry leaders,
practitioners who've
embraced mobile
and who've actually
built a very, very
solid, successful presence
across the platform.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming our panelists.
First up we've got
Manish Agarwal.
Manish is a CEO of
Nazara Games, one
of the largest gaming
publishers in the country today.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome, Manish.
Manish is feeling
very happy these days.
Two out of the top 10
titles on Google Play
right now belong to
Nazara, so good job.
[APPLAUSE]
Next up, we have
got Varun Khurana,
who's the CTO of
Grofers, India's leading
online on-demand
delivery service.
[APPLAUSE]
Grofers has about
12,000 suppliers, right?
VARUN KHURANA: That's right.
KUNAL SONI: And services
about 35,000 orders a day.
So great job.
And finally, we've got
Deepak, Deepak Abbot.
Deepak heads-- welcome, Deepak.
[APPLAUSE]
Deepak is the head
of mobile growth
at Times Internet, which is a
digital arm of the Times Group.
Deepak oversees
mobile initiatives
for Gaana, "Economic
Times," "Times of India"
and a host of other apps which
are part of the umbrella.
Welcome, gentlemen.
ALL: Thank you.
KUNAL SONI: Great.
So the way I was hoping that
we could do this was probably
have each of you
talk about one thing
that excites you about
the smartphone opportunity
in the country today,
and what's that one
big bet that you have for 2016.
Let's start with you, Deepak.
DEEPAK ABBOT: Yeah.
I think sheer
numbers, India is yet
to actually see the
real revolution.
70% are yet to come online,
so that's a big number,
while we have 30% online,
which is 300 million,
which is good enough
for us to create
some great things, great
games so that we've
got millions of users already.
But 70% have yet to come online,
plus 200 million people who
are on 2G.
They're yet to experience
faster internet.
So once that happens, we
see the scale of growth
that you're seeing now
growing exponentially.
So for me, I think that's what
excites me for years to come.
KUNAL SONI: Fantastic.
Varun, how about you?
VARUN KHURANA: So in
our case, our use case
I think is fundamentally
very, very mobile.
Because when you're ordering
groceries or things that you
use on a day to day basis,
you realize most of the things
when you're probably in the
kitchen or somewhere else,
right?
So I think just the fundamental
use case of ours is very,
very-- it is just a
smartphone use case,
and-- which is the
biggest reason why
we're mobile only
till date continues
to be a part of our plan.
And just the fact
that how smartphones
have been growing in India
across tier one is great.
We're now in, like, 25
cities across India.
And you know, we're kind
of continuously seeing
all the growth there, as well.
So this presents a
great opportunity for us
to kind of take this use
case all across India.
So you know that's--
KUNAL SONI: [INAUDIBLE] million
smartphones every month, right?
That's, like, a huge number.
VARUN KHURANA: Yeah.
KUNAL SONI: All right, great.
Manish?
MANISH AGARWAL: I
think my biggest
bet is I believe that gaming is
going to be far bigger than TV,
Bollywood, everything
here in this country,
because it's a device which
you carry all the time.
Share of time is highest,
snacky content is highest.
I've been going to a lot of
forums of media entertainment
sector where gaming really
gets some shady corner.
I believe that the biggest
bet, which a lot of people
are not really looking at, is
gaming becoming a mainstream
entertainment.
That's the biggest bet
which is going to happen.
And that's the
exciting opportunity
which, what Deepak
spoke about, millions
of smartphone data [INAUDIBLE]
are really going to happen.
And you're seeing green
shoots of it already.
For Nazara, the
biggest bet is we
believe that in entertainment,
content is local.
In movies, it's local,
in TV, it's local.
There is no reason
why on your Play Store
there should be any foreign
games in top 10, top 20.
So my biggest bet
is I would love
to speak here in the
same conference in a year
and change that.
That's my bet.
KUNAL SONI: OK.
Good.
You've set the bar high.
[APPLAUSE]
Tell me, so Manish,
just building on that,
thinking about user
trends, you believe
that gaming is going to
be like a big opportunity.
What are those one
or two user trends
that you've seen specifically
on smartphones that you
think will help that phenomena?
MANISH AGARWAL: I think
a couple of things
from a gaming perspective.
The Indian gamers are not the
gamers which a lot of people
think are the gamers of
US or Europe or wherever.
We are not a gaming
nation, and we
are having our first brush
of gaming with smartphones.
And hence, if any
of you are looking
at building games
for India, don't
get influenced by
your own likings,
by your own things in which
you think that, hey, listen,
I was playing this
quality of game on console
or I love "Clash of Clans,"
and hence I need to do that.
Think of that guy who
has no idea of gaming,
it's his first
brush with gaming.
Keep it simple.
Keep it easy.
Keep it casual.
The things like text-based,
narrative-based, FTUE-based--
first time user
experience-based--
doesn't work.
It's an easy pick up and
play game mechanics which--
just keep it simple.
You may sometimes
feel that hey listen,
my game is really dumbed now.
That's fine, guys.
Your users need
to be [INAUDIBLE].
If you are making for
that 200 million people,
then that's what
you need to look at.
And second thing, I think I was
listening to previous session,
app optimization
for low-end devices.
Keeping each and every
KB of the file size
as like a [INAUDIBLE]
state, and really kind
of valuing that every
KB and saying that boss,
that needs to be optimized
and optimized and optimized
relentlessly.
I think these are the two things
which I kind of put in there.
KUNAL SONI: OK, great.
Varun, how about you?
What are those two
interesting user
insights that you're seeing,
given that you are a startup?
You've grown very quickly.
It would be great to
understand what you're seeing
as far as users are concerned.
VARUN KHURANA: So in our
case, the biggest thing
that we have seen, and which
we kind of expected and was
validated as a part
of the process,
was just the repeated
behavior of consumers.
And you know, there's
this big worry that,
when you have an app and if
a user does not continuously
use it, then it
kind of gets lost
in the maze of all the apps
that are there on the phone.
And you know, God knows when
he or she will open it up next.
So that was one big thing that
was on our minds at the time.
But I think, in
our case-- and you
know, I'm glad we were
proved wrong in this case--
that just the repeat
purchase of users
was so high that, in most cases,
what we see is that Grofers,
once a guy gets the hang
of it, so it kind of
is amongst those apps that
is placed on the home screen.
So I think that was huge for us.
KUNAL SONI: That's interesting.
So have you done
anything in particular
or launched a new
feature that's helped
you drive repeat consumption
or repeat purchases?
VARUN KHURANA: OK.
So we continuously think
about all the things
that we can do to kind of
get the guy to, you know,
shop more and more and more.
And we have like a huge
roadmap, right, simple things.
So in the most basic thing--
and which is like brain-dead,
right-- is just notifications.
Fortunately or unfortunately, I
think they really work for us.
And I think this is
something that you'll
kind of hear from a lot of
e-commerce companies out there.
You know, that is the reality.
The other things
which are increasingly
getting huge for us is
just, like, basic reorder
functionality.
So this is stuff which we are
kind of very, very actively
working on.
Basically all the functionality,
being able to predict like,
if I know every so often
you buy atta from Grofers.
So even before you know that
you're running out of it,
we'll tell you that hey,
you'll be running out of it,
so order now.
So I think these are some
of the things or use cases
that we are now starting
to move towards.
KUNAL SONI: Excellent.
Deepak, over to you.
DEEPAK ABBOT: For us, vernacular
has grown like 4x in last one
year.
KUNAL SONI: Wow.
DEEPAK ABBOT: So
just to give you
some numbers,
"Navbharat Times" used
to do about 4 million active
users on their mobile browser
site.
Now they do around 21 million,
just on the mobile browser.
KUNAL SONI: Wow.
OK.
DEEPAK ABBOT: So
in last one year,
because of better
phone support for Hindi
and obviously a lot of
people coming online,
so that is really
working for us.
Not just Hindi, in fact.
We launched in Tamil,
Telugu element.
They have been the
fastest growing.
So TIO has grown, let's say,
about 45%, which is good.
But considering what
"Navbharat Times" and all
these local languages
are growing,
that's like a huge opportunity
still because we believe
that at least we can take
"Navbharat Times" alone
to about 100 million users.
So that's one thing.
And time spent.
So overall, for Times internet,
we have about 50 million users.
Last year, we had
about 25 million MAUs.
100% growth on MAUs, but
300% growth on time spent.
So people are actually
spending a lot more time
on their smartphones.
So that's really one thing
which is standing out.
KUNAL SONI: So the point of
vernacular is very interesting.
is there something
that you've done
to make on-boarding of
vernacular users easier?
Do you think they
behave differently
compared to the traditional
English language
consumers, or--
DEEPAK ABBOT: It's
actually different.
So they spend less time, but
they create more sessions.
KUNAL SONI: OK.
DEEPAK ABBOT: So that's
why we focus more
on the mobile browser
site than apps.
For example, "Navbharat Times"
is about 2 million app users,
but that's 21 million
on mobile browser.
That's like 10x.
And we've tried-- and most of
them are on Android, actually.
They have Android phones.
But somehow they don't
upgrade to an app,
which is OK with us as long
as they are staying with us.
So we made sure that the
site which loads for them
is really, really fast,
because you understand they
come from tier two.
They come from [INAUDIBLE]
where the connectivity is not
that high.
So just make sure the first
bite is delivered instantly.
We use less images, and we
use more snacky content,
I mean rather than
having long articles,
because you know that's
how they like to read.
Keep it short, use
more Bollywood,
use content which
they relate to easily.
So obviously improving
the infrastructure,
for example, our caching
Indians have really dramatically
changed the last one year.
And that actually
had not just NBT,
but all of their apps,
which we've been serving.
And we see great change in
the way the images are served
or text is served, so
that really helps us.
And plus, of course,
on the app side
we've been making sure
that since NBT users,
they come from tier two.
The devices they
use, very low end.
So we test for almost
170 low end devices.
We only use libraries,
which are actually working
on most of the handsets.
So we eliminate
libraries on average--
we have [INAUDIBLE]
focus on features,
but make sure that it
works for everybody.
KUNAL SONI: It works
for at least the lowest
common denominator in terms
of-- OK, great, fantastic.
So what would be your number
one challenge getting into 2016?
DEEPAK ABBOT: I think
a challenge right now
is for us-- not just for
us, but for the industry,
I'm believing, everyone must
be facing that challenge
on the retention side.
While you are acquiring users,
but also losing a lot of users.
And there are reasons
which are internal,
as are a lot of
external reasons,
like this huge noise
about, he stole my app,
this land grab happening.
There are at least
50 companies shouting
about who stole my apps.
Handsets are still limited.
Connectivity is still limited.
Space on device is still
very, very limited.
So while everyone
focuses on the app size
to make it less so that
we will install more apps.
But I think the space
it takes on the device
is far more important,
because that's
what forces users to
uninstall the app.
For example, for TOI
the caching alone
would be 100 MB
about a year back.
So now we brought it
down to about 21 MB.
But that's still high.
We're seeing how
do we still-- it
has to be a balance between
maintaining a cache,
so that people can actually
browse it easily, and still not
consume a lot of
space on the phone
so that people don't
uninstall the apps.
KUNAL SONI: So since you operate
a portfolio of very different
apps, is there something
that's worked particularly well
in terms of keeping
the size optimal,
or taking something from X to Y,
in terms of reducing the size,
that the audience
would find useful.
DEEPAK ABBOT: We focus
more on UX, less on UI.
So I think the prime
example is CricBuzz
and a lot of people
come to me saying,
hey, it's a very bad looking UI.
But that's by far the number
one cricket app in India.
It's about 40 million
monthly active.
We don't really care about
if people don't like our UI,
as long as they're coming
back, 75% retention.
We spend less than maybe
$10,000 in the entire year
on marketing.
So people are coming
back again, and again.
And for us, UX matters, and
that's where we focus on.
When I say UI, I think
there are a lot of sexy apps
out then in places where
people-- on Twitter,
on Facebook, you
meet in your circle.
They would compare that with
some of the Google apps.
But I think for Indians,
they want their content
to be served instantly.
They want it to work.
Our belief is make
it for masses.
I think that's what works.
KUNAL SONI: Good,
that's interesting.
How about you, Varun?
What would be your
number one challenge
as you step into 2016?
VARUN KHURANA: For 2016, OK.
So see, we have kind of--
it's very interesting.
Our journey goes, we started
off from the more affluent
customers to now we are
going down the chain.
So it's a little bit different.
We started off from
Gurgaon and then
Delhi NCR, then
Mumbai, then Bangalore,
which is like all the metros.
And data connectivity
is relatively better,
people have better handsets.
So we did focus
on the aesthetic.
So I've heard a
lot of good things.
People tell me all the time
about just the feel of the app.
So that has worked very
well for us so far.
But now increasingly what is
happening is that Grofers,
we've seen a lot of
explosive growth.
So up until two,
three months back,
we were barely in 10 cities.
Now we're in like 25.
So now we are starting
to see that change where
optimizing on the APK
size, the bandwidth
that we do over the
wire are now going
to start becoming important.
So that is now going to
be the focus for 2016.
So we have already started
doing all of that stuff.
So get all the images
converted to [INAUDIBLE] that
was just talked about.
Our app is very,
very image heavy.
It helps make it look
aesthetically appealing.
So those are, I would
say, the bigger areas
from our technology standpoint.
And one way we're
very different, also,
is that we have a big
offline component.
If you look at our
app reviews, you'll
rarely find anything
about the app, per se.
It's more about
delivery in the area.
These are things that the
offline component of the app
that becomes more important.
So that is, I would say,
an equally important chunk
that is going to be a
focus for us for 2016.
Just optimizing that
for the bigger cities,
and the tier two cities as well.
KUNAL SONI: How
about you Manish?
MANISH AGARWAL: I
think for us begins
distribution [INAUDIBLE].
If you want to reach to masses,
it's going to be via devices.
So we are talking to all the
OEMs and we are saying, hey,
can we embed games
in your devices.
Because we want to prevent
the final drop off,
people not having
enough balance,
not having enough money on
data, and can availability
to drive consumption.
And that's where,
absolutely what Deepak said,
is even getting
into an MB space.
Usually you think that because
you're using smartphones,
they're also
selling smartphones.
You believe that
an MB is nothing,
but then you realize that
10 MB is a huge thing.
And then they say, sorry,
we can't embed your game.
And the challenge
which we face is,
how therefore you make a
game in 5 MB, 3 MB, 4 MB,
and still really
look at it, which
had some semblance of graphics,
some semblance of something.
So we are constantly
grappling with that situation,
that at one point you're trying
to really raise the quality
while another time the belly
of your market cannot support
the install.
Now extended problem, even
if he downloads over there,
it's ultimately going
to reside in his phone.
And if it's taking 18
MB, 15 MB, then uninstall
is going to be very high.
So you're acquiring users,
you are spending money,
but uninstall is happening.
And then it doesn't
create a [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the challenge
is, how do we really
create a game which
can have retention, yet
be part of the constraints which
the ecosystem really offers.
KUNAL SONI: So as a
successful game publisher
with two top titles, what
would be your advice to people
who are looking at
building out a large user
base for their content?
MANISH AGARWAL: In fact,
we are dabbling with this.
We have done a couple of things.
Common game development
platforms like Unity or Cocoa,
make a strategy choice.
If you are India-focused,
you may actually
go with the Cocoa Studio
2D and don't have Unity,
because 5, 6 MB
of Unity gives you
the baggage, as an
additional baggage.
Now you can stretch the
argument even further.
If you are looking at
India, 90% Android market,
your game is not of
the highest quality.
Maybe then you can take
a call that, hey, listen.
IOS I will figure out later.
I'll only make Android.
Then you can make some
calls off native apps.
And that also saves you 2 or
3 MB of further development.
So we are continuously
debating, should we
start making games in
native so that the 6 MB,
7 MB baggage of the development
platform we can get away.
Because writing SDK
plugins and whatever it is,
it's not a very
difficult kind of job.
So my advice is be
clear about your market,
be clear about your
strategy, and then
the choices which you make
for the tech stack are going
to be a very big success
factor as you really
evolve into-- you're creating a
scalable, sustainable business.
KUNAL SONI: So Deepak,
a question for you.
As somebody who runs
a portfolio, again,
of different apps,
can you share a couple
of examples of things that
have worked for The Times Group
to drive up user
acquisition and engagement.
Maybe name a couple of
apps and see what's worked.
DEEPAK ABBOT: Yeah, so for
us since most of our apps
are around content, so
content is one of the biggest
source of acquisition for us.
So breaking news, and bringing
the latest content, latest
Bollywood music, latest video.
So that really helps us and
plus using the technology.
So for example, we've
been staying ahead
of the curve-- so app indexing.
For example, one and
a half years back AT&T
were the first apps to do that.
Music actions, which Google
launched about six months back.
Gaana was the first one
to bring in music actions.
Why search on Android.
Gaana was the first
one to integrate that.
So things like
technologies, Google
is coming out with things
to bring in organic users.
So just make sure that
you leverage all that.
And acquire users using your--
obviously the app quality
has to be good,
content has to be good.
But what we've also seen
is that the biggest source
of acquisition for
us, thankfully,
has been Play Store
featuring most of our apps.
And that doesn't happen
just because they like us.
You need to make good apps.
You need to use best practices.
And their review process is
really, really stringent.
They'll send you a
thousand things to fix.
So even if they
don't feature you,
at least the review
you get from them
will help you improve your app.
So we make sure that we work
very closely with Google team.
All our apps are following
the best practices.
Even if they don't
feature it, at least they
keep sharing feedback with
us, and make sure that all
of the technology that is
available to us through Google,
or otherwise, we
just embrace that.
So for us acquisition, I think
content, using good technology.
And we focus more
on, like I mentioned,
retention is
becoming a big issue.
So we focus a lot
on the engagement.
So last one year, we
shifted our marketing budget
from acquisition to engagement.
Now it's 60-40, so we
spend 60% on re-engagement.
And not just spending money, but
also the tools which we build.
We are focusing mostly on
the customer life cycle,
and where do people drop.
So most of the people
would drop on day three,
day five, day seven.
So what can we do to actually
stop them, and either
use push notifications, or SMS,
email, or any other channel
where we can bring them back?
We've been using re-marketing
on Google extensively.
And surprisingly, we're
getting a CPC of one rupee,
one rupee 50 paise just
to bring the user back,
which is really, really cheap.
So considering that the cost of
re-acquiring a user, especially
if the user uninstalls the app,
then getting him to re-install
is very, very expensive.
So it's better that while he has
the app installed for first two
or three days, or
four days-- even
if you if use external
channels-- just
make sure that you engage
with them and bring them back.
So re-engagement definitely
is the biggest focus.
Acquisition is happening,
thanks to a lot of new users
coming in every month.
So just make sure
you make good apps.
Acquisition for me is
relatively less challenging.
Retention is, I think,
the biggest focus here.
KUNAL SONI: So to Deepak's
point about quality,
I strongly recommend-- I'm
sure lots of you already know,
we have a portal.
It's developer.android.com,
which actually
has all the core app quality
guidelines that we typically
recommend for apps on Play.
So do spend time understanding
those guidelines in case you
haven't.
Great.
So Varun, a question for you.
As somebody who is now seen as
a leader in the very interesting
offline-- well, online
to offline space,
hyper local online to offline.
DEEPAK ABBOT: Offline to
online or online to offline?
KUNAL SONI: It's
online to offline.
Well, whatever.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DEEPAK ABBOT: O
to O. It's safer.
KUNAL SONI: So what
would be your advice
to people who are thinking
of hyper local services
and succeeding in that space?
VARUN KHURANA: Yeah.
So the interesting challenge
in this whole offline
to online thing is
that you are kind
of enabling the
whole something which
is done in the physical
world, and you're kind of
trying to make the users
do it in the digital world.
It kind of becomes a
chicken and egg problem.
So first you need to get enough
offline so that it makes sense
to a consumer.
Because I mean
otherwise, if you don't
have enough of that
meat, then to a consumer
the value proposition
decreases big time.
So with us, I guess one of the
things that worked very well
was that when we started
off as a B2B player--
So initially we were
doing deliveries
for the offline merchants, and
we had a whole bunch that we
were doing them for.
And then I guess the
transition to online became--
and when we first
launched the app.
So we were building the
business for a while,
and then we launched the app
and into the consumer business.
So that helped in a way, because
a whole plethora of merchants
were already on board, and
getting that hook was easier.
In the hyper local
space, I guess
the one thing which all
of you should think about
is getting that hook.
Because I mean otherwise,
it's like I said,
it's going to be a
chicken and egg problem.
Who do I attack first,
and how do I reach out?
And so I think that
hook is important.
Other than that, in the mobile
world I mean in general,
user acquisition is not cheap.
At least for the kind
of users that we go
it goes north of like
$100, so it's not cheap.
And we have done all
kinds of mediums,
all the newspapers, the
radios, Google of course.
We have done a whole plethora.
It is expensive.
I think that hook that
you create I think
can go a long way.
KUNAL SONI: Fantastic.
So one last question
for all of you.
Please share with the
audience one winning tip,
or one winning
strategy that you think
people can start implementing
based on your experience.
Let's start with you, Manish.
One thing that's worked
really well for you.
You'll have to be
a little louder.
MANISH AGARWAL: I
think staying true
to-- A, first being very clear
who is your target audience.
And then staying true to
needs of that target audience
in all aspects, whether it's as
I said tech, UI, UX, retention,
your content, since
gaming is content.
My piece of advice
is, just be very razor
sharp clear on who is your
user, whom are you targeting.
Because if you are
confused on that,
then everything else will
be garbage in garbage out.
KUNAL SONI: Good, Varun.
VARUN KHURANA: So
what worked for us?
I mean, like I said, business
kind of has a digital component
and it has an online component,
it has an offline component.
KUNAL SONI: But specifically
on Play and Android.
VARUN KHURANA: So on Play, I
would say the initial success
that we got was just a lot of
people talking about the wow
factor when the Grofers
app just came out.
The experience was amazing
that when you order,
within an hour the
thing was at your door.
In some cases, we did it in
like 30 minutes or something.
So I think that
initial experience
that we were able to
create created lot of buzz
where a lot of people were
just talking about it.
KUNAL SONI: So sort of
quantity and utility that--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
VARUN KHURANA: I think that
was the one that created
that initial buzz about it.
And then after that, good
old means to get to users.
KUNAL SONI: Deepak.
DEEPAK ABBOT: I think
I'll repeat what I said
earlier, made for the masses.
Just make sure that you
know that your app appeals
to millions of users.
And luckily we are in this space
where we have Bollywood, news,
cricket, which actually has
us bring millions of users.
So for us, I think making it
for the masses is something
which has really worked.
KUNAL SONI: Great, fantastic.
With that, we come to the
end of the discussion.
I hope you found that useful.
Please give a round of
applause for our panelists
for sharing their insights.
[APPLAUSE]